ARE.
BRIAN: SAYS HE REGRETS VOTING
FOR JOE BIDEN AFTER THE
PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED STRICT
VACCINE MANDATES.
HE SAYS I VOTED FOR BIDEN AS
McCAIN REPUBLICAN IT WAS AN
ERROR YOU NOW REGRET IT.
THURSDAY NIGHT'S CHEST BEATING
ONE OF THE MOST DIVISIVE
SPEECHES EVER GIVEN BY A U.S.
PRESIDENT WHO CLAIMS TO BE A
WELL REASONED EUROPE NIGHTER
ACTING ON SCIENCE.
JOINING US IS DR. HOOMAN, WHAT
BROUGHT TO YOU THAT POINT?
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIAN.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I WAS REFLECTING THIS PAST
WEEKEND ON THE 9/11 REMEMBRANCE
AND I REMEMBER BACK IN 2001 HOW
ESSENTIALLY EVERY MEDIA OUTLET
WAS UNITED AND TRANSMITTING THE
SAME MESSAGE.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE IN A POSITION
WHERE OUR COUNTRY FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY DIVIDED AND, YOU
KNOW, FRANKLY AS A FRIEND TO
JOHN McCAIN, YOU KNOW, I FELT
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN STANDS A
CHANCE OF UNITING THE COUNTRY,
ACTING ON SCIENCE, TAKING DOWN
THE TEMPERATURE, IF YOU WILL.
AND, YOU KNOW, ON THURSDAY, I
FINALLY CAME TO THE RECOGNITION
AS IMMUNOLOGIST BASED ON THE
RIGIDITY OF THIS MANDATE AND THE
MASSIVE BLUNDER THAT'S CONTAINED
WITHIN IT THIS IS NOT HAPPENING.
I HAVE TO SAY THE MANDATE AS IT
STANDS ESSENTIALLY IS TO OPEN
THE DOOR TO DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST 80 TO 100 MILLION
AMERICANS NATURALLY IMHUMANITY.
THESE FOLKS ARE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
POINTED TO THEM AND OPENED THE
DOOR TO MASSIVE LEVEL OF
DISCRIMINATION.
IT'S NOT JUST VERBAL
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LOSS OF
EMPLOYMENT.
I CAN'T TELL YOU THE NUMBER OF
EMAILS I RECEIVE EVERY DAY OF
AMERICANS WHO ARE NATURALLY
IMMUNE AND I KNOW FROM A
SCIENTIFIC PERSPECTIVE AND I
KNOW SOME OF YOUR GUESTS IN THE
PAST HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
CERTAINLY DR. MAKARY HAS BEEN ON
WITH TUCKER AND VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT POSTS.
NATURAL IMMUNITY IS AS
EFFECTIVE, IF NOT NO SO THAN
VACCINE IMMUNITY.
SO THE NOTION THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES LEAVES THE
DOOR OPEN TO THIS LEVEL OF
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST A MASSIVE
CLASS OF AMERICANS IS JUST
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
BRIAN: DO YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS
STRUCK BY WITH YOUR HUGE -- WITH
THIS RICH BACKGROUND UNIVERSITY
OF PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS IS YOUR AREA OF EXPERTISE.
BUT YOU SAY IT'S UNSCIENTIFIC.
IT'S ILLEGAL BUT YOU ALSO SAY
IT'S UNETHICAL TO GIVE SOMEBODY
A VACCINE WHEN THEY HAVE NATURAL
IMMUNITY AND IF 75% OF THE
COUNTRY HAS ALREADY GOTTEN ONE
SHOT AND FACTOR IN THE NATURAL
IMMUNITY, MAYBE THERE IS
SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON HERE,
DOCTOR.
AND MAYBE PEOPLE AREN'T
VACCINATED AREN'T VILLAINS AS
THEY ARE BEING MADE OUT TO BE?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK CERTAINLY
THERE IS A PLACE FOR IMMUNITY
MANDATES, RIGHT?
I MEAN ESPECIALLY IN PLACES OF
PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT.
BUT THE REALITY IS AND THE MIDST
OF THIS OUTBREAK, THERE ARE
ABOUT 100 MILLION AMERICANS
ACCORDING TO CDC ESTIMATES WHO
ARE ALREADY NATURAL IMMUNE.
THESE FOLKS ARE FOR THE MOST
PART THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
ARE ACTUALLY IMMUNE AND I THINK
THE NOTION THAT, YOU KNOW, IF
ANY PARTICULAR SUBSET OF THESE
FOLKS WANTS TO AVOID THE
VACCINATIONS AT THIS TIME, THEY
WOULD BE FORCED AT THE RISK OF
LOSS OF EMPLOYMENT OR
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
I THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
DRACONIAN.
BRIAN: IT'S NUTS.
>> FRANKLY IT GOES IN THE FACE
OF MEDICAL NECESSITY AND,
FRANKLY, I THINK IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF LITIGATING A CASE OUT IN
MICHIGAN AGAINST MICHIGAN STATE
UNIVERSITY, THE PLAINTIFF IS
GINA NORRIS AND NEW CIVIL
LIBERTIES ALLIANCE IS GOING TO
BE LITIGATING THIS IN FEDERAL
COURT.
BRIAN: GOOD.
>> THE IDEA IS THIS ACTUALLY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL THING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE CLASS OF NATURAL --
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS NATURALLY
IMMUNE.
I BELIEVE IT'S MEDICALLY,
ETHICALLY INCORRECT AND
CERTAINLY IT'S VERY LIKELY IT'S
CONSTITUTIONALLY A VIOLATION AS
WELL.
BRIAN: I CAN'T TELL YOU AS
SOMEONE APOLITICAL LIKE YOU, A
DOCTOR WHO IS AN EXPERT IN THE
FIELD SAYING IT HAS SO MUC